Joe: I lived in New York City for years,
and it has some of the
best food in the world.
I invited my friend Harry
Kersh over from the UK
to teach him how we do things
slightly differently here.
We'll be visiting four
of the top burger spots
across the city all in one day
to see if we can find
New York's best burger.
This is "Food Tours."
First stop of the day, JG Melon.
All right, buddy, today
we're having the best burgers
in New York City. How you feeling?
I'm excited. Burgers are
maybe my favorite food.
Joe: Thank goodness. Well, starting here,
JG Melon. Have you heard of this place?
Harry: I have not, no. Tell me more.
Joe: I wanted to start
here because this place
does burgers traditionally.
You know, like, smash burgers
and piling it high with
ridiculous toppings, no.
Here, they serve the double beef blend,
griddle-cooked burgers. They
do it simple. Cheese, onions.
We might get a little bacon on ours.
Simple ingredients. Simple
setup. Going to taste amazing.
Yeah, the vibe in here I'd
say is pretty traditional.
It's quite low-key, old-school decor.
Don't accept cards, which is annoying.
Gotta run out and get some cash.
But, yeah, I'd say the
menu's fairly simple.
Classic, nothing too flashy on here.
I feel like you were pretty
impressed by UK burgers
when we were touring London.
Yeah, I was.
We had fantastic burgers,
but, I mean, it's next
level here in this city.
I don't know how else I can put it.
I'm excited to see what I imagine to be
a pretty traditional
American cheeseburger.
Joe: The taste is going to
blow your mind, I guarantee it.
Joe: Hey, fantastic.
Harry: Look at these!
Harry: Ooh.
Joe: Let's go.
Server: Is there anything
else I can bring you two?
Harry: Thanks so much.
Joe: No, that's good.
Harry: Think we're all good.
Joe: Thanks so much.
Server: All right, enjoy.
Harry: They have not skimped
on the bacon.
Joe: No, they have not.
They have not skimped
on the thickness. I mean,
come on, man.
You're not going to get anything
thick like that in the UK.
This is ridiculous.
The only thing in the UK
thicker than this is me.
OK. What do you think of that —
you're getting the American bacon today.
I'm just, I'm ignoring that.
[Harry laughs]
You're getting the American
bacon today, too, buddy.
You got that crispy, thin.
Harry: I feel like often when
you get bacon on a burger,
you get the full strips.
Joe: Hate that.
Harry: I quite like this,
because they've kind of diced this up.
So therefore, I guess
when you bite into it,
you're not just going to accidentally
tear the whole burger up.
Optimal eating. Get some
of this onion on here.
Harry: There you go.
Joe: Come on.
Harry: I'm putting the pickles on.
I know you're not a pickles guy.
Joe: Cheese, look at that.
It's melted right to the burger.
It's done to perfection, dude.
Harry: My God, I'm so excited.
I can't really wait anymore.
Should we just crack in?
Yeah, let's crack in.
All right, man.
Mm. Mm-mm-mm!
Man.
Joe: It's an absolutely fantastic burger.
Uh-huh.
Perfect flavor.
Harry: Did you get that, like, juice
just pouring out of
that as you bit into it?
Joe: Oh, look at that. The inside?
Yeah, that is medium
rare. Perfect. Perfecto.
The one thing that's
really impressed me is that
it doesn't feel too dense, I would say.
When you're forming the patties,
sometimes there's too much of a temptation
to really pack the meat in there,
and you end up with a
much chewier texture.
Whereas this is still so
melt-in-your-mouth soft.
It's really, really impressive.
Joe: How does this compare
to UK burgers on a whole?
Good question.
Joe: Thank you.
Harry: Yeah.
Joe: I'm a journalist.
Asking questions is kind of my job.
And the fact that you like that one
really means a lot to me.
Harry: High praise. I think one thing
that's standing out to me
is the way it's cooked.
I don't think it's super
common in the UK for someone
to actually ask you how
you want your burger cooked
unless you're at a slightly
more high-end restaurant.
So I think that generally
implies that they're using
fresher ingredients. Everything
is being cooked to order,
and I think the end result there
is a really fresh, juicy burger.
Joe: I totally agree.
It's thick, it's juicy.
The meat was so perfectly packed.
It's crazy good.
Back there, they got
the broiler that kind of
finishes the cook of the meat, right?
Before they put the burger in there,
that's when they add the cheese.
Not adding the cheese on the griddle.
It's almost like they're
broiling the cheese to the patty.
Harry: Mm.
Joe: Genius move.
So it's almost like
Saran-wrapped with cheese,
the delicious flavor,
and also adheres the cheese to the meat.
Ah, this place, man.
I mean, come on. I feel like
I'm in the '70s right now in New York.
I'm in Midtown Manhattan
having a big, thick burger, cup of coffee.
I was going to say, this
place feels even older
than the '70s, maybe. This
feels like a really retro place.
I mean that in a complimentary way.
Very old-school. Retro vibe.
Joe: Yeah. I mean, this is
where you go for a long lunch,
couple of drinks, burgers
with the coworkers.
You go back to the office
and do literally nothing.
Harry: No work. [both laugh]
This might be the one to beat.
I know we're just starting,
but, I mean.
It's laid down a gauntlet
already, I will say.
I know we've got more
burgers to eat today, but ...
Yeah, yeah, so slow down, slow down.
This is getting finished
again, man. I'm sorry.
Joe: That's OK. I warned him.
Harry and I had some time to
kill before our next spot,
so we took a stroll through Central Park.
Harry saw a turtle.
From there, we made our way
to another New York burger staple,
PJ Clarke's.
New spot, PJ Clarke's. All right?
It's a New York burger institution.
I know there's a lot of facts here,
but one fact I think is hilarious
is that Buddy Holly
proposed to his wife here,
and it was their first date.
What? That's moving a little bit fast.
Joe: Yeah. I think he was just,
I don't know. I mean, maybe he knew.
Oh, also this was Sinatra's joint.
He always sat at table 20.
Where's table 20? I want to
sit on the Sinatra table.
I think this is it right here.
No, this can't be the Sinatra table.
So it's like a jazz-legend hangout.
Joe: Yeah. Dude, this
has been here since 1884,
which I'm assuming when jazz was popular.
Sure.
Joe: Did you notice
outside, there's, like,
corporate building plazas all around us,
but this building's almost standalone?
Harry: It's really funny.
Joe: How cool is that?
Yeah, they really held out,
and thank God they did,
because, I mean, like I'm saying, man,
this might be the best
burger in New York City.
We're going to be the judges of that, Joe.
Speaking of, which burgers
are we going to be ordering?
Nat King Cole, baby. We're
getting the Cadillac.
Harry: The Cadillac?
Joe: We were getting bacon anyway.
You know, they have other
ones that look like fun,
but I think bacon's a
nice, [clicks tongue].
Get that on every single one.
Harry: I gotta get my fill of that good
crispy American bacon while I'm here.
Joe: That's right, that's right.
You can't get the type of
bacon anywhere in London?
You can in some places,
but it's way less common.
Particularly on a burger in a kind of,
well, it's effectively
like a pub-slash-bar vibe.
Although obviously with a bit more
of a fancy-dining aesthetic.
You can't bring your own bacon to the pub.
You could smuggle some in, maybe.
Get some pocket meats going.
Joe: With your own ranch?
Yeah, yeah.
I like the vibe in here.
It's busy. Popular spot.
Joe: The checkered red and white.
Harry: This seems very
classic. Old-school.
Joe: They filmed some
"Mad Men" stuff here.
Like, they came here in "Mad Men."
And that's the perfect fitting.
Like, getting to work,
drinking all day at work,
then going to lunch to drink martinis.
Sure.
Joe: Before you go back to
the office and drink more.
Cool.
And then you get loaded at happy
hour before you drive home.
You had me up until
the driving-drunk part.
Drive your giant tank
Cadillac out to Long Island
to get home at, like, 9 p.m. for dinner.
Harry: Dreamy, yeah.
And unwind with two
more glasses of Scotch.
It's a miracle anyone made it
out of that generation alive.
Honestly, yeah. How did we not
just go extinct in the '50s?
Joe: No clue.
Harry: Ooh-hoo! Thank you.
Joe: Yeah! Oh, my man.
That's a big burger.
Joe: Thank you, Eduardo,
I really appreciate it.
Looks delicious.
Brace yourself. We gotta talk
about it before we eat it.
Harry: OK.
Joe: Also stacked. This
one, thick cut of tomato.
Lettuce on the bottom. OK? I
like the lettuce on the bottom
because I know it makes
everything go every direction.
It's kind of isolated from
the rest of the toppings.
Very smart, very smart. A
thicker, more smokier bacon.
This might be the best bacon
you're going to see all day, my buddy.
This looks crispy as hell.
Joe: And you notice onions
underneath for some reason.
Harry: Are you going to put
your onions in the burger?
Joe: Yeah, of course.
Harry: And the pickles on the side again.
You can pickle your own burger.
Joe: Yeah, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Harry: Which I feel like you might skip,
but I'm definitely doing.
Burger, some assembly required.
Joe: Yeah, dude.
Harry: Hit it with the pickles.
This thing is huge.
Joe: This thing is just dripping.
Harry: Mm. Oh, my God.
My plate looks like the
floor of a slaughterhouse!
This is perfect! All right, ready?
I think so.
Joe: Bite, my guy. Let's do this.
Harry: Get my optimal angle for bite.
Joe: Wow.
Wow.
Oh, look at the inside there.
That's cooked perfectly.
We said medium rare, right?
Harry: We said medium rare.
Joe: Yeah, perfect.
Harry: Another place where they asked us
how we wanted it cooked, which, again,
I think is a good sign, cooked to order.
And they nailed that as well.
Joe: "How do you want
it cooked?" is code for,
"We're paying attention."
Harry: Mm-hmm.
This is so good. This is so fantastic.
Harry: It's a serious burger, man.
Joe: The consistency of
the bacon on this one
might be perfect.
It's crunchier than normal.
I like how it's got a bit of bite,
because everything's so soft.
Had a few concerns about
the assembly, maybe.
Because when you have things
like one big slice of tomato,
big slice of lettuce, and
large pieces of bacon,
sometimes when you bite into it,
you can pull everything out by mistake.
But it's really holding together.
I'm liking the bun as
well. Because somehow,
despite the amount of moisture
that's been coming off this,
the bun's holding together, doing its job.
Joe: It's not falling apart at all.
Harry: No.
Joe: Oh, wow.
Wow, wow, wow.
These fries are nice and crispy, too.
Harry: Mm.
I wish the UK did bacon like this.
I'm willing to admit when the US
does something better than the UK.
I think bacon's a good example.
Because you guys even have
those bacon sandwiches.
The bacon buddy? Bubby? Buddy? What is it?
Harry: Butty.
Joe: Butty?
Harry: Mm-hmm.
I can't believe you guys are literally
having bacon sandwiches and nobody's like,
"Hey, why don't we make
this a little bit crispier?"
Harry: Yeah.
Not one person has made that conclusion.
I wish we would. I've
had too many depressing,
very pale rashers of
bacon. It's not for me.
Bacon's a real bummer over there.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
What do you think about
the beef patty itself?
Joe: This one's, like, the perfect size,
and with all the toppings
together, it's just so good.
Harry: I think they can only get away with
putting this many other toppings on it
because the patty is so
thick and juicy and meaty.
Not falling apart at all.
It's packed in there, man.
Which I love.
I did think that I'm not getting
as much of the cheese coming through
in the cheeseburger part of it.
With this one, the cheese has
less of a presence in there.
When you want a cheeseburger,
you really want to
taste the cheese, right?
I think I kind of come and go on that one.
I do think that American
cheese is the best cheese
for a cheeseburger.
Melts without splitting.
Hear that?
I also don't personally want
a ton of cheese on a cheeseburger.
I know that might sound a bit weird.
For me, it's more like a
little accent to the burger.
Joe: Really?
And almost more of a
textural thing as well.
Joe: Well, this is amazing.
I feel great, but we got more
burgers to eat, buddy, so.
We do. As much as I'd
like to hang out here,
have a few more drinks,
maybe move to martinis,
I feel like it's time to go.
Yeah. Couple more burgers, then
we start drinking martinis.
Let's go.
Harry: Let's do it.
Joe: Eh.
Harry: Too fast, man.
And then I did it too.
Joe: After that, we
headed over to Brooklyn
for our next burger,
at The Long Island Bar.
All right, this is The Long Island Bar.
It's been open since 1951.
And also, I think you'll
like this place too
because it has more of an American menu.
There's cheese curds and deviled eggs
that I want you to try too.
Harry: Yeah. Never tried
either of those things.
They sound like classic
American foods. Would you agree?
Joe: Oh, definitely.
Harry: Yeah.
Joe: Also kind of dig the Art Deco vibe
in this spot too, right?
Harry: It's really cool.
Joe: Like the '50s diner vibe.
Harry: Yeah, I feel like
tradition has kind of been
a hallmark of this burger tour so far.
It feels like we kind of stepped
back into a time capsule.
I'm really liking it.
All right. I am dying for
a burger. How about you?
Yeah, I think I can do maybe
one-slash-two more burgers.
Joe: Let's do it.
Harry: Cool.
Ooh, here we go.
Look at these!
This is a spread. Dude.
Joe: Like the American flag in here
to let you know where you are?
I'm taking mine out, you leave yours in.
This looks like a Krabby Patty.
Oh, yeah!
It's like the perfect cartoon burger,
which honestly makes me
want to eat it so badly.
No time to waste. I'm taking a bite.
I'm going in. I can't
wait to taste this bacon.
Harry: I don't want to
accidentally eat the American flag,
so I'm going to move that one.
Oh, my God.
Mm! Mm-hm-hm-hm! Dude!
Oh, man.
Joe: You're kidding me with this.
And with the special
sauce they have on here.
OK, I gotta go for another one, oh.
That is crazy.
This is the secret weapon
right here. This bacon.
[bacon crunches]
Harry: How have they —
I need to know how
they've done this to that.
Because the shape is amazing,
and the crisp on that?
Joe: Something that you
don't see in the UK either,
they batter the fries.
Harry: Battered fries. That's the most
American thing I've ever eaten.
Joe: Yeah, right.
Instead of it being one thick one,
two half-thickness ones,
double it up with the
cheese in the middle.
Harry: I'm seeing, like,
there's pickles in the middle.
Joe: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You see that?
Harry: They've layered it really well.
Joe: Sealed in deliciousness.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
Joe: Yeah. Oh, this is
so good. And the bun?
Harry: A bit more texture to the outside.
Joe: Uh-huh. Mm. Oh, God.
Harry: This thing's ridiculous, man.
It's fantastic.
Harry: Yeah, you can tell
a lot of thought has gone
into the assembly of this burger.
Joe: And I like, because it's two patties,
there's a meat-to-cheese
ratio that's better here
than it's been anywhere else.
Yes. Don't let that precious
cheese go to waste, my man.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
And the, I mean, the star of
the show. The secret weapon.
Bacon floss? I don't
even know what this is.
It's fantastic.
Harry: Bacon spiral.
So, I love the American vibe to this.
The owner is from Wisconsin.
You know what else is from Wisconsin?
Harry: Mm-hmm.
Joe: Cheese curds.
Cheese curds.
Joe: I don't know if you've
had one of these before,
but you know what this is?
It's a ball of deep-fried goodness.
That's all you need. Cheese, right here,
in curd form, fried, boom.
Get in here. Get in here.
What is that, like, ranch sauce?
Joe: Yeah, but it doesn't need it.
It's so flavorful. It's so good.
He's bringing these in from Wisconsin.
Harry: Mm.
Joe: Right?
Really pleasing texture on that.
Joe: Yeah, it's great.
You can see why this is, like,
an obsession in the Midwest.
Yeah, wow. Nice and chewy.
Not overly cheesy.
More just like a sort of
chewy, savory mouthful.
Joe: It's a snack. This is
a Midwest snack right here.
You can go to town. I
think I need a few more.
Harry: I am concerned for
the health of Midwesterners
if this is a snack, but ...
Joe: Oh, they're fine.
Harry: Very tasty.
Joe: I don't think there's
really an obesity problem
in the Midwest at all.
Harry: No?
Those colorful little
white guys in front of you,
deviled eggs.
Hard-boiled eggs, you
take out the yolk ball,
whip it up with spices,
and reinsert it in there.
So even though it's a hard-boiled egg,
it has a softer texture to it.
Harry: OK.
Joe: And this place,
usually they'll throw
in paprika or something
to give a little bit of a kick.
They have their own house-made hot sauce.
Harry: OK. Putting their own
little twist on a deviled egg.
Joe: Yeah. Get in there.
Why are they called deviled eggs?
Why are these, like, unholy?
It's because they're a sinful pleasure.
Are you joining me on this one,
or are you watching your cholesterol?
Joe: No, I'm watching my cholesterol.
I want to see your reaction.
What do you think?
Harry: Mm.
Joe: Yeah, right?
That hot sauce, man. Nice gentle heat.
Joe: What their competitive
edge, I think, here,
is that they're leaning into
the Americana-ness of it, right?
A double burger, dripping with cheese,
delicious sauce, ridiculously good bacon.
I don't know where this bacon's from.
Harry: No.
But I absolutely love it.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
Battered fries, battered
cheese curds, devil's eggs.
And martinis.
Joe: Yeah, I mean,
Harry: Delightful.
this is like a niche that
you don't see too often
in New York or anywhere
outside of the Midwest.
It's really kind of unique.
There's nothing like this in the UK.
I've not had this experience before.
It's Cobble Hill.
It's not the tourist center of
New York City, certainly not,
but definitely worth coming out to.
Or people who live in Brooklyn, visiting.
But yeah, this burger's
ridiculous. It's so good.
It's a thin patty, but it's not smashed.
Not a smash burger.
Because we're not getting
that kind of golden brown,
crispy crust on the outside.
But I will say it's very well
seasoned. It's very flavorful.
They did lettuce, no tomato.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
No onion in there, either, right?
I don't think so, no.
Just a lot of pickles,
cheese, that incredible bacon.
Yeah. The meat did the
talking in this one.
Harry: Mm. Which, honestly,
I kind of think is how a
cheeseburger should be.
Yeah, I agree.
Harry: Let the meat do the talking.
Fantastic.
Ooh, I'll wash down with
this refreshing martini.
Cheers, my good man.
You look like you're enjoying that.
Should've gotten a beer. Ah.
All right.
Killer burgers, place is getting packed.
Feel like we're taking up
valuable real estate here.
Got one more spot to
take you. You want to go?
I do, yeah. Popular spot,
let's clear out and give them some space.
Joe: Let's go.
I wanted to show Harry a place that takes
a slightly more creative
approach with their burgers,
so we headed up to Rolo's in Queens.
I don't know anything.
I don't know anything about electricity.
I want to say that. I
don't know a f---ing thing
about electricity. Like, nothing. OK?
So we've establishing
I don't know anything?
I'm pretty sure that's not right.
Harry: No, that does not look good.
[both laugh]
Joe: The f---?
Harry: That can't be safe.
Joe: No way the electric
company got in the cherry picker
and got up there and was like, "Yeah."
"Looks good. Cool, cool."
Harold.
Harry: Joseph.
We've eaten our way through
New York City via burgers.
We have.
Last place, here in Queens,
Rolo's, one L, not two.
Not to be confused with the
very sweet chocolate candy
with the caramel center.
Burger here is supposed to be bomb.
Wanted to end the day here.
Little outdoor dining. Alfresco.
How you feeling?
I'll be honest, not great.
[Joe laughs]
I think my eyes ...
Why?
I think my eyes might have been bigger
than my stomach with this shoot.
Joe: Oh, really?
As you'll remember, I
was kind of putting away
the entire burger for the
first couple of spots,
thinking I was plain sailing.
I don't recall saying anything.
No, I don't think anyone did.
If only someone had told me,
that would've been great, but.
Yeah, so it's the crew's fault.
Yeah, I blame everyone except myself.
Yeah, very smart. Man, you
are becoming an American
more and more every day.
Hey, I've made it.
Joe: So, the house burgers
here, everything is fresh.
I believe the meat blend
is 75% lean, 25% fat beef.
So you're going to be getting
a nice savory flavor in there.
Everything cooked on an
open wood-fire grill,
and not a flattop, which is a distinction
from all the other places
we've been to today.
They only make a limited
number of burgers each day.
Harry: Yeah. I'd say
it's a lot more modern
than the other places we've been today.
It's much more of a cool, hip spot,
rather than a very classic
New York-style institution.
Joe: Yeah.
Harry: Music's playing, lights are dim,
candles are lit, you know.
Nice place to take a date, maybe.
Yeah. Getting a little mix of everything.
If this video was a little longer,
I would've taken you to White Castle,
but apparently that doesn't count.
Harry: Thank you.
Perfect. Look at those.
Joe: Fantastic.
Thank you so very much.
Server: Absolutely. Y'all enjoy.
Joe: What'd I tell you
about this place?
First impressions, what
are you thinking?
I was trying to get a photo of the burger.
Joe: Yeah.
OK, do your BeReal. Let's go.
Harry: Real quick, real quick.
Because this is a photogenic
burger, I would say.
Yeah. I mean, how beautiful
does this thing look?
Harry: It's pretty gorgeous.
I will say, right off the
bat, this looks very different
to the other burgers we tried today.
Joe: Look what's going on here.
They're searing the top of the buns?
Harry: Searing the buns.
Joe: Didn't see that before, right?
Harry: We got the bacon.
Look at the color on
this bacon, by the way.
Joe: Yeah, it's different than
other bacon that we've had.
That looks really good.
Yeah, it's a really bright red.
Harry: Two beef patties.
There's some caramelized
onion on there as well.
And, of course, some cheese.
Joe: This is closer to, like, a,
I don't think they're smash burgers,
but they look more smash-burger-like.
Harry: Much more like a smash burger.
Because you can see you've got, like,
bits of caramelization on there.
Joe: Mm-hmm.
Harry: It's like dark crust on the burger.
Joe: Yeah, pretty impressive, right?
Might be something to do
with the way it's cooked.
It's cooked over the wood fire?
Joe: Mm-hmm. Yeah, no, yeah, exactly.
Sorry, I'm mesmerized by this burger.
Harry: You're lost in
the burger right now.
All right. I gotta bite before we talk.
Harry: OK, man. Last one of the day.
Cheers, my guy.
Oh, wow.
The onions on this thing, too.
Mm-hmm.
This thing is fantastic.
You can just taste the difference
with the wood-fired meat,
versus something that was on a grill top.
They put cheese in between both patties.
It's a lot cheesier, but
the sauce too is incredible.
I can't get over the onions, actually.
Whatever they're doing to these onions,
they're, like, dipped in garlic
butter or whatever, right?
Harry: Like, garlicky, caramelized.
Joe: Yeah, yeah. That's incredible.
A little bit of sweetness.
Joe: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really like the mustard
sauce on this, actually.
It's a mustard-mayo-type thing.
Little bit of pepperiness.
Yeah, it's got a bit of Dijon-ness to it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everything's working so well together.
This is one of the more juicy ones
we've had today too, right?
In a crowded field, yeah.
I feel like they've all been pretty juicy.
That's a recurring theme,
but this one definitely,
again, you squeeze it,
a lot of juices are running out of it.
Joe: Mm-hmm.
Harry: The onion juices
all just kind of mingles
into one delicious broth.
Really impressive. It's probably
the most inventive burger
we've had today. Right?
Definitely stands out.
Look at the color on that, on that bacon.
It's maybe not as crispy
as some of the other bacon that we've had.
Joe: No. No, no, no.
But the flavor is fantastic.
Joe: Yeah, the flavor's
definitely locked in there.
I mean, I think everything
about this is really, like,
all the positives, the
flavors are jumping out at me.
It's because it's cooked in wood fire.
Harry: Yep.
Joe: That has just unlocked
the flavor in the meat
that we weren't really getting
from the other burgers.
Flavorful, right.
Joe: Yeah. With the grilled onions?
Harry: Mm-hmm.
Joe: No other burger today has been topped
with such flavorful extras,
if that makes sense, right?
Price-wise, this burger
lands in the middle.
It's $18, but 3 extra
dollars for the bacon,
definitely worth it.
So 21 bucks for the burger
and a big long pepper.
We been eating burgers all day.
I feel like if I was having a normal meal,
just this burger would
hit the spot for me.
It's a big burger.
It is a big burger. I think
this would fill you up.
I also think, like, location-wise,
we're a bit further out
than we have been for the other ones.
The first couple were very
central, Manhattan-based.
Then we kind of moved
more out towards Brooklyn,
and now we're in Ridgewood,
which I guess isn't as
much of a touristy area.
Joe: More of a neighborhood, yeah.
Location considered,
I think this is more of a high-end burger.
Well, it might be kind
of in the middle to high
end of the price scale.
I do think you're getting a
lot of quality for your money.
They clearly take a lot
of care over their meat,
the way they prepare it,
the way they cook it.
And it does show through
in the final product.
It's a very, very tasty burger.
Joe: Yeah, very tasty.
[motorbike engine revs]
Not very considerate of
people filming around here
on the roads, are they?
Joe: No.
But I think we're all
impressed by how loud that was.
Oh, me too, yeah.
Hard choices have to be made, Harry.
[engine revs]
[both laugh]
I get it, it's fine.
There's another f---ing bike.
Nicole: I was just going to say,
this is a very big motorbike area.
It's a motorbike and bus area,
which is really convenient.
[engine revs]
Oh, my God, so cool.
Four of the best. We did
the London burger episode,
so I had to respond with the
New York City burger episode.
Overall, what'd you think of
New York City burgers today?
I do think we've had some really
fantastic burgers overall.
I also like how the different spots
have kind of represented
different parts of,
I guess, New York culture as well,
from the very traditional kind
of bar, tavern kind of vibes
to the more classic Americana diner style.
And, of course, the
people who are doing it
a little bit differently,
putting their own spin on the classics.
I like the variation that
we've had today as well.
I like how some of them have been
the more thick-cut patties.
Some of them have gone for
the thinner double options.
All of them have been
really, really juicy.
All of them have been pretty flavorful.
I will say, I don't
know. Compared to some of
the London options, I don't
feel like New York is doing it
necessarily a lot better than London is.
Joe might disagree.
I disagree.
But I feel like in terms
of the actual beef,
the quality of those meats,
I do feel like UK farmers
are holding it down.
No, I don't agree with that.
I'm sorry. Our beef is
superior to yours. All right?
I don't know how much
clearer I can put it.
USA is beef.
So, break it down.
What is your favorite and why?
[sighs] Man, if I had to pick a favorite.
You do.
Harry: Of the burgers that we chose today.
Contractually obligated
to pick a favorite.
Harry: I am.
I think if we had to pick a favorite —
[motorbike revs]
More f---ing scooters.
Joe: Same guy?
[camera crew laughs]
[engine revs]
Harry: Oh, my God.
Very tough decision.
I think my favorite of
the four we had today.
Joe: Yeah.
Long Island Bar.
Whoa.
Harry: Long Island Bar.
Really?
Mm-hmm. You look surprised.
I guess I'm not.
Harry: No?
That was a really good burger.
Harry: Really good burger.
Yeah, that was my No. 2.
A, the vibe in the place was really good.
I like it in there. Very,
like, classic Americana style.
Really cool.
I think the thing that
stood out for me, though,
was the care they took
when they were assembling
that burger, the way that it was layered,
ingredients equally distributed
throughout the burger.
Joe: Yeah.
Harry: Fantastic.
The beef itself really well
seasoned, really great flavor.
Lots of pepper and salt in there as well.
Joe: You even pointed out
the seasoning on that one,
didn't you?
Harry: I did. It really,
really stood out to me.
Wow.
Yeah, I just think overall
that was my best burger.
Joe: Wow.
Harry: How about you?
That was my No. 2.
Harry: No. 2, OK. But No. 1?
It's tough because JG's and PJ's,
those places to me are,
like, New York City.
The vibe, they had that,
like, we're in Manhattan,
we're popping in, getting
a burger, getting a beer,
depending on what time it is.
The ambiance, the fact
that they're doing it
the same way they've been doing for,
you know, 100 years or whatever,
and they've been there that long,
clearly they're doing something right.
So both those burgers had, like, a taste,
a classic, traditional
burger taste that I do enjoy.
Now, Long Island Bar, your favorite,
I picked up on all the
things that you just said.
Would maybe have been
my favorite of the day.
Harry: Mm-hmm?
But the best burger that I had today
is our boy Rolo's. This one right here.
The flame-grilled, the
quality of the burger,
the 75:25 ratio of lean to fat.
This burger is fantastic.
I'm very impressed with how good it is.
I love the bacon on this,
love everything about it.
The bun, how it works together.
The second I bit into this, I'm like,
"Yeah, we have a winner."
We've been eating burgers all day.
That's a testament to
how good this burger is.
On our way over here,
I'm like, "No, not another burger place."
And then I bit into it, I'm
like, "I'm so glad I came here."
It's a fantastic burger.
The other three places, also amazing.
I think the quality of
the meat, like I say,
probably highest at Rolo's.
Really had that beefy, meaty flavor
that I really want when
I bite into a burger.
So I do think that if it was purely a case
of, like, the flavor of
the beef burger itself,
they may have been my No. 1.
Joe: OK.
I think overall I was
factoring some things
into my decision, like the vibe in there.
I just love the Americana.
It was a little bit kitschy
in The Long Island Bar.
Joe: Ah, I see.
Harry: But I love that. As a tourist,
I think that's what people
want when they come to New York
for an authentic burger experience.
Joe: I never thought of it like that.
Harry: So that factored into my decision.
The burger itself was still fantastic.
I'm not just recommending it on the vibe.
But yeah, I think all in
all, as a total package,
recommending this to other tourists,
that would be why I'm making my decision.
I'm so tired.
Harry: Really tired.
So very tired. People can
tell watching this video.
The sun is going down.
We're both going to get
gout after this trip.
Joe: Bring it on, baby. All right.
To White Castle!
Harry: To White Castle? [laughs]